hello everybody this is Yvonne tiss here
and I want to give you guys a small
disclaimer before this episode starts
lord kognito was out in packs and the
audio i got from him is not of the
highest quality that we usually like to
have so i do apologize there will be a
couple echoes of me probably coming
through on his a little bit and his is
definitely not this clear quality he was
used in like a headset instead of
actually a good mic because he was
traveling so it was a really good
podcast so i apologize about the audio
not being prime on this one you guys
know I have been trying to work on that
for everybody so it is a great listen we
get into kind of a crazy heated debate
chat was amazing when we were doing this
one so if you guys listen to this one
live on Twitch you guys are awesome you
guys can't catch these live on twitch.tv
slash montes but it was a really fun
episode so enjoy the listen find some
way if you want to hit us up on Twitter
YouTube comments things like that let us
know what you guys think because this
debate is going over a couple episodes
now over this whole weapon retiring
thing so enjoy the episode and I'll talk
to you guys later alright and we are
last minute addition of the last word
with Laura Kathleen Oh Eddie bachas
super super spicy and super hot can't
fire the people water it I wanted it
even from backs are what about all the
levels they are not the greatest I could
not miss the show for the world
especially after last were the last last
word so II first of all how are you
doing how's your victory lap right now
no idea what you're talking about I'm
not sure what you're talking about sir
I'll just say the timing of everything
that has happened you know has been
insanity I mean for one Europe abuses
like you like yeah alright so I just
want to break this down for everybody
last week this man called me out for not
teasing like texting him for this little
like two-second like 10-second log in 45
second teaser with his man nose iris hey
so good god the god make sure you stay
right and then it's like it's Tuesday
night right yes Tuesday night
so Tuesday the reset everybody is
getting all their fractal line we're
getting close you've seen the numbers
climb I'm like all right we're getting
close now we had previously seen from I
want to say Dylan
dmg oh for that hey there's no don't
expecting don't expect a quest or
anything of that nature they kept the
expectations fairly low so this man was
sleeping about 9:30 gonna say 9:30 ish
is when the fractal line finished okay
when the fractal line finished the
beacon in the tower got a little change
you can to kind of had a log in and log
back out right and from there when you
came back to the tower obelisk there'd
be a little thing and it popped up a
little like mini questing it's Edworthy
so you went you basically lit the beacon
in a baby cinematic it's kind of
cool-looking your character would go in
the middle
you took the lantern of Osiris plopped
in the middle of this thing on Mercury
and this beam of light shot up in the
air because you know we're calling out
to all the guardians out there in the
universe trying to call all the new ones
and such so after that you went back to
the tower and you're like cool does it
pretty simple and sweet
they then for those were yeah save your
title so if you guys were waiting on
those it's done so you let the be
confident I know brother boy that's your
first title I literally have so many
congratulations on your first one way to
go it's like my sixth so so then for
those of us following like bungees
twitter because we're waiting for the
picture for them to say complete when
that happened when it's a complete
that's for one when we know we could go
actually talk interact with the obelisk
they also had just a little youtube link
on the bottom of the tweet saying hey
you guys completed it youtube link you
clicked on that and it would send you
over to a YouTube that was gonna
premiere in about 25 minutes from when I
clicked on it and it was they literally
said trials of Osiris season of worthy
developer insights and this is the point
when I see this I start texting this man
I actually picked the phone and called
him and I got
I got a dead silence a I even made a
whole video and sent him the damn link
that he had before he woke up so by the
time he woke up two texts a phone call
and a video all about all the stuff that
happened but man mom trials is gonna be
coming I got us here how are you feeling
from when all this went down yo let me
tell you all right first off salutes
about me II but making things right like
this not only did he make you but he
went above and beyond the call dude he
said the ninja needs to know I don't
care how he's sleeping I don't care
what's more I couldn't say a courier
over to your house and knocked on your
door I would've done sleep bro bad law
like to get the message again normally
normally I would be up during that time
that's why I was that's why I was
calling you so much it was like why are
you Bobby
cuz I switch normally I'm a vampire so I
I'm awake during enemy but I always had
to stretch my skin because I'm going to
be a daywalker that so I gotta be a
daywalker I had an early train so I did
the responsible thing I'm like okay I
figured fractal eyes it'll be finished
but they're not gonna announce now like
I don't even deep that was the last
thing for my mind at the honest I didn't
either they had the expectation solo
solo somewhere okay they probably do
some little cinematic maybe I'll find
out I said I'm going a bit early I will
be responsible I go to bed I wake up to
the voice by the text everybody's
hitting me for mom man II with the first
so I checked it out and then yo let me
tell you right now it was ridiculous
read because I got three them to love it
but on it was absolutely insane I saw
the trailer and let me tell you if a
grown man was almost ready to tear up
when I saw that Egyptian armor when I
saw it at hour when I've literally saw
my
more like Armour of time and then you
see in the classic maps and then they
did the pinup and luke swift talking
about Brees and how much it meant to him
and literally it was my life flashing up
on the screen like let me explain some
female we why go crazy right I'm not too
good but the widow I'll go crazy is Ben
ray tough I'm a gaming at it the way you
guys go crazy or a way he goes like
crazy Pete Krause is my reign I've only
been in a lighthouse turn but it's the
greatest moments in death remember him
destitute and remember when they did
those um remember what you did like
almost like pass the time in destiny one
yeah so don't fall back I remember
people are my fire team like you don't
say a shot so a couple of people that
you know that play by the wrong time
then I'm like wow I remember with little
light up like those are the thing to
remember for this be it the CD
egyptian-themed to see oh say trials of
old salads
don't travel to die and states voice it
was literally storybook for me I went in
saying
Christmas came and February jumped on
the train biggest cool a smile you've
ever seen in my life
I was heaven man and there's a shuttle
de that was amazing
watch out let me ask you for personal
let's say you don't hate that thing hate
crowds but I know you escaped with what
was your feeling you saw first time just
the fact that I was waiting 24 minutes I
was like aren't Hammel how long am I
getting ended up being about four
minutes that's a little tease it was a
nugget at 10 o'clock at night honestly
that was the fun part yeah if you can
turn me down there any good you do you
go so it was cool just the fact that it
was like timed now granted it was a
YouTube premiere and I know how those
work so there's somebody sitting at home
waiting to be like alright so Dok set
that moot bump it out like 30 minutes so
they just had the time like two or three
days from now like unlisted and then
they're like okay set the premiere for
10 o'clock for my time is 8
clock their time I think so it was cool
to see I like the logo as you're sitting
there waiting for it the logo on the
wall was pretty cool
hi I'm Bob Oliver all the books as well
right now oh yeah this man is gonna buy
everything from that Bungie store next
season we owe everything he can buy so
then we got the premiere and just Luke
Smith Hawking like if I could ever get a
chance to interview that guy yeah I'd be
I'd be good
just ask the interview Luke oh he's so
genuine and for somebody at his level to
be to be able to be so candid and kind
of like really but he's still he still
knows how to play the proper like
corporate transparency but he does it in
such a candid nature just like dude I'm
just having a conversation with this guy
so just those little bits like talking
about trials we knew in the title that
it was coming and then they started
getting into it they're like okay you
got the og Maps coming back I was like I
have way too many memories on all three
of those oh they got Exodus blew that
one definitely I think that was a later
addition it was an OG map was it no that
was later later edition you had cauldron
which I was like makes sense they're
gonna do they're gonna give it a shot
keep neat job shadow key and then
anomaly is what I've been waiting for
the anomaly map the like just it's us
very it's a circular map and we don't
really have as many of that shape which
is very cool to see it fits more with
threes the smaller tight quarters like I
won't Rumble on that map I miss Rumble
on that one it's so much fun so and they
all have good different themes to them
so the maps are cool now there's been a
giant controversy about one of the
things that was said in that video and
this is like what two or three hours the
two common ones that we mentioned and
then what the big one in there is I
would say it's a controversy but there
is a small contingent of people I'm
gonna attacks that friend right now shot
the set but you know you know I got mad
low
but anyway so here's the deal I get what
you say now the
say look I'm that try hit on y'all we go
that's just me skin of oh it's little
old it's table man I get it I get where
you're coming from I cannot deny that
categorically to the letter of the law
yes but don't understand or tap this is
a call back this is an emotional fall
back to the flying error of foul they
are going to give us new honor but
they're going to give us that but those
are the most beloved stacks in that
water out that that was peak trout so
don't get it twisted we're gonna get the
other newer ski for this I'm telling
that was a nostalgic thing look at it
like that don't look at it is easy I
think I mean that's the nostalgia is
there to some point because there's a
lot of people that have been asking for
it in itself but honestly in my mind I
see it more safe than nostalgic
absolutely because you have a 3 B 3 mode
based on this and when it comes to Maps
that they know work they have a goal
that they brought forward but they
wanted to have a couple that they know
have been used for this mode before so I
honest I will say like I enjoy the maps
and like for them you'll be able to
bring multiple maps in in a season when
we typically don't get strikes or
crucible maps or anything if this is the
way they bring them in yes it's safe I
would like to have seen like three and
maybe one new one that they may have had
some time to design just a little
freshness I'm not sure how well I wanted
to ask you on the armor as well as the
armor itself there's one picture I took
a bunch of screenshots from that video
mmm there's one picture that is it's
like the three I think the Warlocks
kneeling down the hunters on the left
and it's kind of as it's slowly zooming
in the night no mobile no basically it
looks like it's almost in like the
chainmail kind of mostly the gold black
and gray day but then it's the Warlock
in the hunter and it's basically there
to cloth pieces the robe and the cloak
have the teal now is that teal coloring
always there am I forgetting or is that
kind of a new touch that's a new so
that's like a new shader touch I was
introduced or what be like the teals
like that wasn't quite there I
yeah that that wasn't quite the I agree
they did to about again like I said I
mean look man the way you have to look
at it from a PvP standpoint the PvE guys
that I kind of bashed it a little bit
later we met remember II when age of
triumph came out 31 mm-hm and they
brought back all the glass it was the
same but they add in the little those
are some of the best-looking armor of
all time they just think they're over
sets right now granted we didn't get the
level of chroma and extension to that
you know I'm saying level what I like
you got put the clothes for people
flawless the little touches and stuff
like that a kid there's one you bring in
the fields back you getting that love
this mold those are the moments they
remember so this was tastefully done
they will give my dad look at T so yeah
they've got similar so we'll say very
similar armor to destiny one their
harkening back to the Egyptian theme
you've got the Anubis helm for the
Warlock you got the little bird beak on
the Titan I got the eye for Osiris for
the hunter so those are similar looks
but you did call out one thing they're
definitely making a throwback to the
flawless ornaments but you're making the
armor pieces glow when you go flawless
and it's a weekly thing at the end of
the week gone yeah so I mean it's gotta
be something you continuously do earn
and go to the lighthouse so that's one
of those things where it's gonna be like
if you want to glow you got to do it
every weekend oh yeah you got to do
every week baby yeah you get a shine
that shallow I'm so high I know you are
yeah it it literally was christosp again
that this is the PvP guys we've been
beaten down but so how long has founded
one under this rain dropped off and cuz
year one of Destiny was year one try a
curse and war mines
when did it leave ice before forsaken
they didn't just like end with forsaken
it was gone before that right it was
before sake so I mean you're a very
shot quite two years were like 15 months
something like that like a year and a
half yeah in DC here that's a rule and
we were talking about the more them that
are fun to get into but um
yeah man we gotta see but that the only
thing I would say let's get back on
track is the only thing that made me
quit was free not hurt I'm like I don't
know how I feel about the masses getting
in and then obviously we did find out at
the time the artifact and me who had a
very extensive quick discussion back and
forth over texts about that so yeah
let's let's get into eat so then this is
all happened in like the past day and a
half like the time is weird cuz this has
been a whole lot going on in like two
days so one of the biggest controversies
for all this in the developer inside
little Vidak thing they said power
matters now they had not clarified yet
but a little bit later between destiny
roundup and read it and Twitter and all
these things there was a question out
there about power mattering wondering if
the artifact was going to affect your
power level and up until about three
hours ago it was going to yes and this
was I mean I can't tell you how many
tweets videos were made follow it put
his one out there and that was his big
one and it was very justified because
the big issue was what oh yeah a whole
like a whole video about it oh oh he had
a whole video about it yeah he's not the
only one there so I mean there's a lot
like the main issue you have two main
issues that like everyone's gonna work
okay three one is just if they deliver
on rewards we won't know that until we
get them that's fine they're just gonna
hopefully deliver second one right
cheating we know it's gonna be apparent
even more so on PC with aimbots and you
know it's peer to peer so your IP isn't
hidden so there's lag and ddossing all
that stuff that has actually been there
since like do you wanna it's just gonna
it seems to be more and more apparent as
people seem to get smarter about it
right but the biggest one that I think
Bungie has control over I mean yeah they
can work on cheating but is the light
level
and Cosmo came out and replied to
somebody asking is the artifact I think
it was a tweet or reddit I don't forget
we're right and said yes the artifact
power will be all like your artifact
power will affect all aspects of the
game including trials and that ol giant
can of worms so what was your initial
reaction when you actually saw that hey
this is gonna be a thing now as of three
hours this has changed but we still want
to kind of go through the whole process
things last couple days get the vibes
back there again I'm getting no much me
you were going back and forth we haven't
a low tech and I'm like II you will meet
us or the same Pope I'm like bro that is
a mistake
because we both know if you separate
artifact grime and again I'm not set to
order or I'm fractal I imported who has
a PV gear you can completely abuse that
system you know I know guys that I was
running around and you know that's the
1080 light crazy right so both eyes are
coming into trial with power enable this
is way worse than like iron banner and
stuff like that and I think what
happened is they got some state is it
like oh it's not for the affected iron
banner the reason was nobody's playing
I'm not as many as played the incentive
it's not there so if you put this mode
that it's free and an artifact blind
people are going to abuse it so I am so
glad and got to where we got some today
because that really would have put a
dent back be even more worse to meet an
anti like in the back of your mind I
think I'll a taxi said of us somebody
set up I'm instead about Twitter you're
always gonna think damn why did I lose
that gunfight with that percentage more
you know I'm saying because that guy was
1100 and I'm 90 yeah it was yeah I was
like I'm attached had a video him and
couple of they're like big predominant
people are sitting there playing like
frostbolt glad they were just chatting
and he posted up the video of them just
talking and basically the biggest thing
is like some people say it's like some
people always worry things in this game
or is a designed for streamers
right the hardcore dedicated play
crapload of ours those are the type of
people who would likely see one of the
biggest advantages of this I mean yeah
you can go farm bounties and lost
sectors on the moon and do that over and
over and over it that's I mean the
people who still play a crapload are
gonna get an advantage but a lot of your
predominant people where this is their
job well still did not want this because
again it's the idea for the masses to
have a chance because the later and
later and later you get in the season
the bigger that disparity is gonna be
and especially if somebody is like hey a
little slow in the season they jump in
they jump into one match and they're
like hey I'm like 961 cool I'm working
on leveled out but hey let me go try
trials this dude is like power level
1020 he's got a 60 power level Delta and
he just people it's not gonna be fun for
them and then your trials easy to
believe but then your trials population
that has potential for a new thing is
gonna drop off hard and fast and that's
the issue they don't want this to be a
mode where people are like hey it's no
fun I'm out like they want to make sure
that even the casual people yeah you may
have like a 10 little difference if
you're not working pinnacles and that's
like incentive to go in there and do
some pinnacle so you can have that
closer match but we're talking a max of
10 we're not talking about 50 for a
casual person so yeah that is HUGE HUGE
HUGE that it would have been bad now you
get I'm just saying three hours ago
roughly like whenever that came out Luke
Smith himself tweeted oh that all PvP
power enabled modes will not include
artifact power so that has been changed
and if you want to see if they listen to
the community right there they had it in
them they had it in the developer
insights Cosmo basically still official
from Bungie community managers saying
it's there and a lot of people and then
they turn around and switch it like 48
hours later video shout out to the
community shout out shout out to me
because it lets me really are
complaining did enough death and and
again I
the only thing I gotta be honest I
question dude why they were fighting uh
I guess I saw a tweet too and I was
wondering it's like and there were three
for us yeah it's like what was the
thought process and there were three
different like somebody was like is it
this this or this and the last one which
somebody else agreed with I wish I could
find the tweet basically they said they
had done testing and it wasn't as
dramatic as they think but the
perception of like the general audience
still thought it was gonna be enough
yeah it just again in the current
structure of the Sandman with this
bounty grind where every activity that
he do you should experience right that's
the new destiny but so this this whole
new gameplay move does it it just
doesn't sit well artifact this goes
against the trials power leveled enabled
concept it just does the best it is I I
don't know why he would be affirmative
but in their defense they think they
came and up they made a last-minute
change the called inaudible in the
fourth corner very last minute and I'm
thinking now I'll show him I'm on my
chemo and chat on a reference to
cheaters that look I'm with love to say
hey that's even worse I get that now in
their defense remember about two hours
ago they were talking about these new
heightened security measures that they
are ready to roll out the ban hammers
gonna be super late you know so we got a
steam you got a hold their feet to the
fire that I am impressed that they even
mentioned it cuz we know that's gonna be
in Perea but I I can't need to know how
the quest is to get in to eat with this
whole 83 that's my only last year and I
saw I saw one person say be like dude
give me a seven-hour quest to get in
trials make it a hell of investment the
first time yeah so those free accounts
just be like oh let me go over here
shoot five people and I'm gonna go like
that no you need you need to be a
lengthy investment so those cheaters
have to actually work hard if they're
gonna get into it and then if they get
banned they're like god I cannot keep
doing this like five hour things we'll
play another match like it needs to be I
mean I'm okay I know that sounds weird
and stupid to be like I want to spend
like six hours in the game just to be
able to go
trials if that keeps cheaters out of it
for a one-time I don't need to do it
every time but one account one thing yes
please yes then that would be too short
it cannot be like go do a PI EP match go
get 10 kills and then you're gonna it
it's gonna be a long lengthy thing I'm
almost willing to deal with it is an IV
style don't-don't-don't rare bounteous
their cognate oh don't don't do that
hey if it means keep the cheaters out
think about the people who really really
want to plays well you gotta isn't think
about how bad you would have liked hey I
will be there I might be a little I
might be a little less well no reverence
but yeah the idea is generally that we
want some pretty decent hurdle for the
people who can just be like oh I'm gonna
go make a new free account that they
don't want to do that a lot I mean the
cheaters are gonna be there some are
more about and the other thing is as
they're saying those banhammer tools are
gonna be quicker and the appeal process
is a bit more there's gonna be an
automation of like the ban is gonna be
somewhat automated the appeals are gonna
be a little quicker
yeah if you have anything happen to you
report them like just because if they
start saying things ready yeah I was
like if you said don't be it's like a
jackass and report people who are just
bullying you yeah don't report people
who are just beating you I mean that's
just a game but if you see somebody's
cheating you think it could be reported
because if they get multiple like
interactions on one person that's gonna
probably trigger something and it's
gonna check a couple things and it's
probably gonna go quicker so that
automated process was set up for trials
I can fetch you that so the I'm curious
about the quest
we've got trials not affected by the
artifact and iron banner - which is good
because I got tired of that crap - I'm
life somebody's got like ten levels on
me they're not gonna out that like yeah
there are so many things would be a lie
not like one shotting oh yeah so we'll
get into sandbox changes and stuff a
little bit later oh we gotta talk about
it so much
Wow so then you got the trials release
I'm trying to think of anything else in
that video got the three new maps 3v3 is
elimination still similar loading screen
like duking it out how we're enabled
then not enabled right the quest to get
into it so it's free but you got to do
the club trying to think is there
anything else we know about trials that
we haven't covered yet just again like I
said that we saw a little some hints of
some guns and stuff like that yeah okay
so yeah yeah one of them was looks like
an ornament for outbreak perfected yes
straight up an ornament cuz that gun
looks too unique I was so happy with
outbreak perfecting you know being that
that wasn't that long quest line for
that gun I'm so glad they preserve
hashtags they've begun
say oh no that's gonna kill me so it's
fine yeah uh but yeah so we no trousers
coming starts on March 13th so it's the
first Friday it's kind of like the rate
of the season three days in yeah
now with short with the artifact not
affecting power we do know that you
don't have to farm as many bounties now
you could start stockpiling some
bounties if you really want to get a
little ahead in the game but the
artifact is not gonna matter so it's
right just about your gear so
stockpiling bounty is not gonna do that
much for you now if you want to go raid
run night falls go run the dungeon
between now and then get a few extra
pinnacle drops to be a little step up if
you've been slacking like this guy then
yeah Friday the 14th will be quick and
you might be a few you levels under but
I can tell you yeah it's not gonna be
quite as crazy which is good and the
experience won't affect anything so you
don't have to save one bounty I'm so
happy I don't have to like bounty farm
that I got a comment though the only
thing they gotta break back is they have
to I would see the classic system the
bowls that kind of stuff yeah I want to
know about like boons and stuff because
that's yes that'll be dating the trials
bounty back
remember a lot of people to check that I
agree and that was their admit your boy
did not get his doctor the past him you
know I'm saying a debt I had the regular
warm up for him the bounty the one that
you completed when you had played a
certain amount of magic not a kill
because what that does is that instantly
died look I'm not good enough to go to
the lighthouse but at least I'll keep
clean because I got the chance every
week for either a trial weapon or a
trials armor and that is key we gotta
see that I want to know that link we
don't know what else oh my god every
system I'm in but if they bring back the
Chows bounty
that's gonna keep the cash was released
try because let's be real it's super
sweaty oh yeah this is more discouraging
than huge amount of people not getting
to the lighthouse right so we got to get
that up and you know so that those
boundaries were made I think that was
like the second season without a plan or
not a difference yeah fell even later
that really got me to because in this if
I didn't go I got stumped
another thing yes apply it the other
thing we did see from Luke is that
matchmaking it's gonna be based on
connection and also on your guard steak
what yes it's heart state connection
basements making now if you were like
what is card state if you guys don't
know trials and if you guys are newer
that's totally fair it hasn't been in
the game in ages basically you have a
punch card you have a certain number of
wins you trying to get to complete the
card and you have a max number of losses
before your card basically is done so
generally it was trying to get nine win
at least in trials of Osiris it was nine
wins and you had an option of three
losses before that card was done now the
big big goal which is why we built the
beacon is to try and get nine wins no
losses and go travel to the lighthouse
when you mentioned the adept gear that's
where you got it that was the Adept that
was the later on it was primaries that
had elementals it was you know your
bigger pieces in this at this point is
gonna be your pinnacle drop of probably
at least for sure a pinnacle drop every
week yeah so it's definitely a PvP
pinnacle drop
and that's kind of the big one we don't
know is the rewards yes we don't know is
it gonna be like a high level piece of
armour is it gonna be a masterwork piece
of armour is it gonna be just a weapon
is it a special version of a weapon with
like another perk on the end like we
don't know how that stuff's not work yet
that armor bonuses please let it not be
like the dungeon armor that dungeon
armor is just BS and I'm trying not to
cuss right now cuz I really want to that
dungeon armor yeah it comes master work
if its master worked at 62 I just want
to slap that armor in the face it's
terrible you got a 50 stat roller yeah
you have ten energy so you can use all
the slots but your stats are terrible
terrible yeah so please like the trials
rewards have to be good all is
guaranteed five enhance I'm dead I need
to get shards those need to be involved
like if you go seven wins maybe that's a
shot like maybe that's a Chartres it
needs to be something like that a week
to be able to have a PvP version to get
these currencies because right now just
in these crazy 980 night falls for those
shards they need to spread the love on
that one
those ascendant yeah that's need need a
bit more out there so upgrade materials
solid armor I want like weapons that are
worth the grind like you go nine wins
you better hope that drop isn't just
like a regular rapid hit kill it like
rapid hit kill clip Auto rifle it's
gotta be something different I'm hoping
I just don't know I'm gonna go big and
we'll get to the weapon discussion a
little later but I do want them I do
want them to stand out even if I have a
struggle getting them I still want them
to stand out so the people I do love PvP
enjoy it I won't say this though I'm
entertaining the thought oh it'll be
kind of cool if they had like a trials
exact I don't know if they'd do it but I
think it would be cool you know saying
but was maybe he'll have a quest like
you go to the light help me get a quest
yeah absolutely but I we got so
and the Boone's will help if you guys
don't know what the Boone's are
basically they would do different things
one of them would count a win as two
wins you wouldn't have to get quite as
many another one would kind of give you
a get-out-of-jail-free card on a loss
and there was a third one and I cannot
remember what it was was like it was
like an extra weight
yes it was yeah one would count as a
double there was a did one just like
there was three she had the doubler got
it one couple of the were see there was
that I can't remember the third if
anybody can either yeah yeah again yeah
I want that arm to be 60 stat at a
minimum you guys are joking it's like 50
and 49 I guess what do you think they
would offer ornaments like trials
warning they owe you big each season of
proud citizens might be or about the
season might be ornaments them ornaments
or different armor sets I could be like
I mean I would like there to be like a
set of armor and ornaments from trials
but if it's gonna be refreshed on the
seasonal basis I don't know how frequent
they can keep building again know where
we don't know how many sets of armor
they can build in the game each year so
region right point good point but I'd be
I'm excited I can't wait there to see
what they cook up reward wise and like I
said they got the formula to definitely
do that didn't you oh I know what I need
though I need browse specific armor
perks for example back in the day they
used to have stuff like faster yeah a
little quick read a little bit something
that really helped with the mole I'm
saying that's across the board in the
game I want rated for ellen trade perks
to back they can get trial my gonna have
to see what the hell this artifact looks
like because we don't know if it's maybe
e they did state anti barriers gonna
matter in pvp now Oh talk about them
tight yeah so that'll be a thing yeah
but I'll be curious see if like there's
anything a bit more PvP focused because
isn't going away after this season so I
don't know if they'll build the artifact
around that as much yeah
so we'll just have to see Bob's back
life is good all life is good yeah so
yeah phase two of a crazy 24-hour period
if you guys have never read one of Luke
Smith directors cuts they'll be digging
up the old ones they're all amazing
greens now you guys hear a disgruntled
kognito and the other podcast get some
drink and put spikes of the oil out
Bourget shout out to bender with the
bits thank you very much sir a little
sword animation so basically sometimes
Luke's will come out into a director's
cut he is the game director coming from
that high up he's got perspective of
those guys play all the time how are
things in the studio what is the
community like what have they learned
from the past six months to a year and
they're kind of giving a retrospective
look and also a glance into the future
to either explain changes that they know
are coming and wit what they learned
these things from so as we go through
he's still I mean I'm gonna go and hit
like highlighted bits of this thing I
did a video on it separately I gave my
thoughts on and so I'm gonna be kind of
more bouncing stuff off you but I'll
still be here the big thing is they want
destiny to be exactly what they've said
before an action MMO single evolving
world that you can play anytime anywhere
with your friends and they said it's a
game they want to keep building on but
they always have to make sure they do it
with the creative and work-life balance
that is sustainable for all the
employees at Bungie and this is one of
those things if you guys have keeping up
with like game development especially
current and news stories and things some
studios do not treat their employees
with like the respect of their time and
work-life balance they want them working
80 90 hours killing themselves to make
sure they pump out content as fast as
possible
now most people who get into the game
industry will have a passion for games
and they're building things that they
have passionate about so it may not be
as much but again some employers can
take advantage with it some of them want
to respect their time in Bungie has been
through that before they've been
crunched they've done the halo things
and back in those days they killed
themselves for hours they decided after
all that was done to say we're not doing
that anymore now they may go through
times of like yeah
we're gonna be working some extra hours
but it's not like insanity they do draw
lines I mean it was the Lord of wolves
fixed we could either do the Lord of
wolves fix now
or we can wait two weeks have a normal
development cycle time and we'll get it
in the next fix and that was one of
those things they call out little things
like that to say hey we're still gonna
give our it's a video game we're not
gonna kill our employees we'll fix it as
soon as we can and that's just a balance
that people need to again remember these
people have lives it's not like oh this
game isn't working right for me using me
you must fix it right now you can't
sleep or have lives like if you go to
work in your job and your boss is like
well these people want this thing so you
have to work 70 hours in one day you're
like well I can't do that well that's
what you have to do like there's a point
where you got to draw a line and I just
wanted to call out that they just take
take a second and remember that when
things are not fixed as quickly as we
would like them to be absolutely and I
want it I want to double down on that
book this standpoint one thing that
first wash out the loops I let that mean
what we say this every director's cut
but I still think it needs to be
emphasized Bungie is probably the most
transparent games video I have ever
covered in the history of gaming most
directors most game designers most Leo
heads who never give you the kind of
things this dies game that the thought
process in his head the thought process
of the studio also telling you about
bandwidth telling you about their former
partners and how things are now
fracturing so I gotta respect it
regardless do I do it every day that
we're gonna get into no but at the end
of the day I respect it because you know
what most games with I'm an act foods
will go out of their way to not reveal
information until they feel comfortable
until they're good and ready you don't
say that just easy look look this is
what we put it you know Sam now when we
do stuff in this fashion that softens
the blow for the men you know Plymouth
doesn't get everybody's through happy
but things they may not like what you're
gonna get - then Lisa's cousin
God didn't have to tell me that he
delivered the bad news to my doorstep we
have to do it so let's get to it yeah so
and one other thing they also said this
is actually a bit of a comfort to Luke
Smith especially up in his level Tim
mark knows where they look just a few
people that have run him Pete Parsons
there's about three people up at the top
there's a time when they broke off from
Activision where their nights were
focused on will Bungie survive that was
their that will they survive are we
gonna get through this and they said now
it's where can destiny go and how can we
get there so they've they've made that
switch over to be an independent
publisher they see that this is like a
possible thing that they can maintain
and that's good news cuz the focus isn't
on are we gonna stay afloat okay it's
like now how far are we going down river
and I like that that's just a good thing
to hear so I have a big thing that he
wants to focus on because this is a
little quote that I do wanna read when I
came back from the holiday this year
something about doesn't he felt off to
me season nine is to me the best winter
season we've had done in destiny too and
I'd say I'd probably agree with that
it's been a really good season but
something felt missing in my I agree
I've been really casual at least I feel
like I've been casual and that missing
element is what I think we need to focus
on throughout 2021 and into 22
throughout 2020 and into 2021 and he
said aspiration a hope or ambition of
something of achieving something now I
mean he states later on I think this
could have been even one of dados videos
quotes he's like there's so much to do
and none of it matters that was one of
the videos there's a lot of things to do
in this game but the feeling of it
mattering has kind of fallen away a
little bit right but he's like
aspiration and trying to achieve
something is different for everybody he
said I'm not so naive as to think we can
make something that matters to everyone
all have different values goals in time
but I do think destiny - can do a better
job of enabling players to set short
medium and long term toward long-term
goals to work towards and I think this
was just a huge piece - no there's gonna
be challenging content but whatever is a
challenge to you to me to somebody who
has like three kids but still wants to
play this game who
sixty hours a week and as a lawyer but
still likes to boot up destiny and
castle on the weekend everybody has
different things they go for some people
like hey I'm just trying to get to like
level twenty in the season pass cuz I
got to play this like an hour a week
then there's people who like play the
game for a living and they're sitting
there at level 300 because they don't
have anything better to do I'm gonna try
in solo night falls you're gonna try and
get to the lighthouse
everybody has different things some are
longer some are short-term so Bungie is
never gonna be able to win every single
battle for every person but they are
going to try and at least work on
getting better at setting different
standards for different people and
getting goals out there that each kind
of level of player be at the casual the
hobbyist the the insane hardcore
whatever gonna call those but like
giving each like level and tier try at
least the best that they can't within
the bandwidth of their studio something
to aspire for what so overall I mean
that's one of their goals for this stuff
so the first thing he talks about his
seasons of change yes so they've had a
couple seasons under their belt since
shadow keep and they've been going
through discussions internal they're
seeing like hey how do the seasons feel
how do the people in the studio feel
what's the community talking about what
are the numbers how is their engagement
what does their data showing what's
their historic year every year's like
all this stuff they're looking at and
they said when they're looking to take
when they're looking at seasons for year
four already talking about year four
we're talking six months in advance
right now and we aren't even in our next
season and we got two seasons to go to
get there they said there's some things
that went well in the past couple
seasons there's some things we need to
work on the ones that went well
they saved the seasonal narratives have
started to connect to one another and
also those seasonal quests and bringing
back saint-14 and I will definitely say
that narrative the season be so good
another one they said the simplicity of
the battle pass just like getting the
battle pass in there I don't it doesn't
hurt anybody and I think it's only a
benefit is it perfect
probably not they could use some drinks
but it is in addition to season so we
did not have before which I think only
adds value I mean how do you feel I know
for the narrative for you that's always
a big ones have you felt even without a
raid without you know any big major
we're just talking about a couple
seasons how is the
that was a story from eros to st. how
these the past six months been for you
yeah it like I've told you it's a year
thing because on one side I people that
were complaining about emptiness and
they're feeling of that but for me he
made a point in this breakfast are the
these were even for he called teacup but
people who were bid with destiny from
the very beginning and for people who
know that low by a dollar
we've heard about the legendary state he
heard about these these mythical
characters and now we're getting to see
them and then coming NPCs I was proof of
Farris before self and I feel about that
but at the end of the day it's more
building in world building that I always
felt missing so again they may not have
satisfied but as far as for the deep cut
I like that aspect yes is a little bit
more cavity this so very reward heavy on
certain levels but I don't feel it was a
misty you know I'm saying not gonna
please everybody okay but I felt for the
most part does in to get what I want to
get done jump out and now they now have
to feel that boy to death for God say
okay I need something to continue to
strive for and for it to mean something
because the team with the seasonal
content on he is a why mines on the
grandest power level is owned will reset
the artifact right or why am I going to
do this and there's nothing those bill
pinnacle he doesn't it was just a lot of
things didn't mean what they used to be
because of the structure or in that
sense I understand change have to have
to also won't talk about seasons they
talk about the art feeling like they're
delivering an evolving world they said
instead of delivering the feeling of
ephemeral private activities and rewards
that go away and it's true we had the
invasions on the moon
which honestly be animation that alone I
love that animation when they come in on
the moon and the VEX were in there and
this also comes into how they're gonna
build their Lord like if the Vexin made
the moon and then we push the vex back
well you know they're not gonna be
coming anymore
but the very offensive while it may not
have been everybody's favorite activity
and did get a bit samey after a while
still is an activity that was built by
developers took time right rewards boss
encounter mechanics AI all that effort
gone December whenever this thing
started what's gone right say he made a
he made a comment about as a studio they
can't sustain that they can't sustain
putting all these resources to what's
creating something like a sundial right
creating something like a flex offensive
and they just the fluid away from Ally
stance the best is completely
unproductive you know so they know that
has changed and then they kind of talk
about what again where they want to kind
of pivot yeah and he said the first
second annual pass while he had there
were multiple studios involved which
they no longer have and again they
mentioned they're like hey our friends
at other studios former studios but they
don't have low anymore areas hi moon
Mike Harris made literally like each
studio made a season only in your pass
you had season of opulence was that
vicarious right yeah Bluto yeah I mean
opulence was like he got the menagerie
the kronosaurus raid he had the big
barge on nessus I mean you had teams
building so much stuff you had season
the for Jim the for gist that was a
little smaller but quicker but you have
four different forges you had also
another raid remember these other
studios were involved those were when
those raids came in when it is Bungie
the bandwidth is not there they are all
right they only have so much but the
cool thing you said about the annual
pass was the fact that if I stop playing
for a season and I came back like if you
played forward skip drifter came back
for opulence there's even more in the
game than was when you left yes the way
it is right now is they're working on
trying to they're trying to make these
moments that are memories like a is the
corridors of time gonna be remembered by
everybody who played yes
but they feel like they're leaning way
too heavy right now on the foam oh the
fear of missing out is almost too much
because like hey were you in the game
for two weeks no I was out of the
country on business will you miss the
coolest thing but you'll never see it
like that yeah it's a bit much but
that's also like whoever developed the
quarters of time every one of the rooms
the in puzzles the whole thing to have
that go away with animation is
too tight so they're working on trying
to make these seasonal activities not be
specifically season esque but kind of
last until the next expansion right
because most people when we go into
season of worthy even if you didn't play
but if you buy season of worthy saint-14
is probably just gonna be sitting in the
tower you don't know how we got there
you're not gonna get to go save him and
their idea would be hey if you log in
with season the worthy well before you
go to trials you probably gotta go save
this guy yeah how about that so I mean
that would be a much cooler way for
anybody at least go and then if you get
to September and you're like okay yeah
if you missed it it's like six months
old okay now you got it it's like nine
months at that point okay well trials
and Saint are here just get on board
like it's been long enough at that point
yeah so it's just kind of that point of
they're trying to find a delicate
balance and there and there those two
ideas are butting heads they want to
make memorable moments but they don't
want to develop content just like that
fades into the vapor yep
yeah it's they they can't sort of trying
to go back and forth and balance these
two which is tough yeah the idea that
they're trying to get at is they
mentioned they're trying to take these
seasonal themes of like sundial and the
time lost weapons and as you said pivot
and put these into some of the more core
activities that they're gonna want you
to play anyway I mean the season pass
has a collection thing so you got to go
play gambit for a while you got to go do
a crucible ritual weapon you got to go
play strikes and get solar kills and all
those things but then also and those
have a lot of bounties related to him
you go to the vallah
you go to gambit you're getting a lot of
experience from those but on the other
side you're like hey well there's this
specific seasonal stuff that's gone in
three months well I gotta go play
sundial there's not really a lot of
bounties there but there's these
specific weapons so I got to play
sundial but then I need to go play these
other things so they want to try and
work on in future seasons kind of
melding those two better so they want to
take those core activities the
repeatable play lists not like a quest
line not a campaign but those repeatable
activities and infuse more of the
seasonal activity into those things so
like take something like the sundial I
mean making these sick person match-made
activities at some point that is gonna
get old so they got a progress tear away
from that
but they also want to say like hey what
if I go in a crucible playlist and I can
get the steel feather or Peter right
that's the general idea is taking more
of these things spreading them into the
playlist you had if you had every time
lost weapon in crucible gambit and
strikes but I just spread all of those
and you have a chance to get a timeloss
weapon by the way yeah yeah that's a
better way of handling it you're not
just giving it away you're putting it in
core activity still have people brandy
if they get a chance for its reward I
can I like that aspect well my question
though is how are they gonna handle it's
still a balance because again a new
season come we introduce a new threat
right most likely still kind of
introduced a new activity are they are
you did they get a pivot away from new
activities they back they don't want
them to go away because of the resources
and then the hard part it's like if you
may like and I mean I think the Sun Dial
yeah if you can kind of turn me down
okay yeah it was lower but yeah to hear
you that way pop that's right so like
that I think the sundial is one and not
all work this way because they're not
all gonna be this way but I think the
sundial is one that I honestly could see
as a strike whoo like that would be one
that could be so that way the
development resources are not completely
wasted it it finds another home in the
game right and I think that would stuff
like late I mean making backs of again
that's the tweak it's six man verse
three man strikes and that's why I was
like I don't know but if they keep
making Mac tivities that have seasonal
themes like the sundial is very specific
something I don't know if anything is
gonna happen at the end of the season
for the sundial to either shut down go
away not be needed but I feel like at
the end of the season it is gone but
sundial activity is going away yes
especially vaddera tableau it has to go
because you know spoiler do it like
apparently um most irises are wily
warlock they like he has some meeting
with the drifter and in order one of the
key component of the sundown
like on me coca beer on up I put it out
like an I'm in car apart some tiny dark
art which only I think the wave I
produced it it can only be one of the
days and what he's like that so that
needs to go because even um Sakura as I
y'all they're really doing this cuz I
look we got it we have to do this I have
to try to say paint at all cost and the
drifter was overlooking he was brought
in to overlook or not from a narrative
standpoint so I think now that state is
back they have to figure out it way back
they can't they did at least in my yeah
so I'll be curious if there's any like
can a wrap-up narrative cinematic thing
for the end of the season because when
that son that's a whole thing I mean you
log into mercury normal not there which
is still weird to be by the way it is
weird you go patrol mercury it's not
sitting there but if you go to the
sundial it's the same damn middle of the
planet yeah so it's very odd that's
that's one of those unless it's like
like here's your normal patrol zone and
then like over here on mercury in
another section this is like unless that
but they don't ever tell you but it sure
looks like it's just like plot or the
public event usually lies so it is it on
but that's I mean that's a struggle they
have right now is they're trying to
figure out a way we want to give you
guys fresh stuff for the season but
thematically it fits in just a season
we're pushing back infects who wanted to
invade the moon okay you push them back
we're done that activity doesn't need to
be there anymore so again they have to
try and both balance the narrative like
that they're trying to move a story
forward but make that narrative actually
also have a functional activity that
might be able to stay around like and
it's not an easy thing to do like hats
off to all of those people and Minds
coming together be like how do we do
this and not this and spend you know six
months making a sundial that's gone and
three like it spends more time to make a
damn activity then it's gonna be in the
game yeah and then doesn't afford to go
away I'm very moving forward how I love
the idea of the loop rule of a thing
like a sundial thus going into core
activity I love that I just want to know
does this mean now blast a little
I just want to know how they deal with
them they did say he did survive from a
technical standpoint it cannot exist
another reason why I can't exist
oh yeah the game cannot hear owing
they've strayed they yeah and that
multiple places from what we know based
on what we've seen that again my boy
Jason crying we had him what he told us
but I had to ask that he's got crazy
[ __ ] and I said I said look they by
themselves you understand the resource
state is destined equally in your a
thing coming and I'm saying like soon
but then that stain caters being one in
two but three or four years whatever it
is we're right now we're about time for
destiny three we have three year cadence
that's what we did before it came so at
least the big it would get the enough in
cases ryan told me i love our cast
oh no they're staying with destiny oh
wow and lo and behold here we have with
the director alright luke literally said
it probative like this is when we're
rocking right you don't see your for
that's not like hey new game that's like
hey there's an expansion seasons coming
in September we're doing this that's
that's at least another year for sure
but sure go to vibe he's gonna be again
and you'll pass a new path expansion you
know taking pass that kind of thing if
they do that then it leads us into what
we'll talk about with God pertaining oh
I'm saving the big one for last don't
worry that's what I'm just gonna let you
jump all over it
so this is like they're trying to take
the thematic world of like these
narrative themes and hey bring in st. 14
and we've got the sundial in time lost
weapons because we're traveling through
time I'm trying to take some of that and
potential in the year for spin that
either put more of that stuff into the
core activities or baby do even more of
it into just the core of the game and
honestly I love that I like the idea
behind it I just want to see how it goes
that's you so that will be the different
the differences it will key and Gavin
said he's like we built a world and this
is the other thing that's kind of this
is why I'm doing this and wait and the
other one till later
because these two built-i together they
said we built a world where players can
encounter encounter others but we
haven't made a world with fights
challenging enough where you feel like
other players matter now this is one of
those things where there are public
spaces on every planet you can just
patrol but I can tell you the only time
you may ever even have a group of people
together that really might care about
being next to each other is a public
event but guess what
yeah almost every public event can be
soloed yeah they're not that hard
anymore the only one who can't sell
those typically because of line of sight
it's the one with the three vex ones cuz
you just usually ancy but other than
that you can solo every public event
that's as big as we go now from other
games that I played I'll use a reference
of what I used last week that pissed the
world' off world of warcraft still had
massive mazes no but okay so these are
massive spaces what I would love to see
take a flashpoint one I would love to
see a flashpoint cranked the difficulty
on that planet up by like 10 right - on
that same flashpoint there is a world
bus and that has an icon on the map that
is a timer countdown and either every
day every six hours there's this just
mammoth of a boss that comes in themed
to that planet and like you need all
night however many people can go to no
one play in it the whole day you know
whatever yeah yep and if you walk up to
him he's just gonna step on you and
squish you like a bug but if you got
like nine people pairing up wells
bubbles over here trade not like trade
and damage hit and crit points whatever
you can do it takes the whole damn
planet like you see it be like
everyone's loaded into this instance
we're gonna be waiting five minutes
crazy dude is showing up we're going to
town got some unique reward to go with
them that other type of thing worthy
public spaces need to get to that's why
I love escalation because it gave me
that feeling
what can you stand because you could not
go in there you could have the best
build the sickest question is although a
serious matter you didn't have the party
you are happy to see another fair in
your play space your instant because you
like man without a shot how happy it was
twenty days and you see four five people
already in your suite we can do nice
yeah like we're going okay I'm going
oh you go in and you buy yourself again
like Oh yep on off you gotta said app
was the booty vest oh that idea with
what you saying fine yeah so that kind
of ties into as they said cosmic Gardens
is the other piece and we're gonna get
to weapons on the director last thank
you so he basically said it frequently
seemed like destiny was treading water
in terms of moving the narrative Ford
they said they wanted to tackle that in
year three and he said that like last
season the narrative has definitely
improved we've seen errors two stories
start to move forward the pyramid ship
has potential but there's still a lot of
things that are just dangling the story
threads out there we don't have a lot on
so they still want to keep working on
that on year four they said the idea
building narrative that is moving the
story of your guardians plural all of
you forward creating a universe where
permanent change is possible and where
players can have a meaningful impact is
the thing we're still chasing and
experiment with we've said before that
destiny to cannot keep growing
indefinitely there are lots of reasons
why this is true some technical some
creative and because the story wants to
push into new areas on the technical
side I come back to sustainability and
this is one of those things that ties
into what we're gonna talk about next as
new areas features and event types are
added to destiny the problems of mate
maintenance grow accordingly for the
team new changes to the system have to
be back checked against all new areas
and old ones the introduces risk and a
big burden of our teams to maintain the
legacy content but the bigger this thing
gets and as detailed as their play
testing goes to make sure is this weapon
balanced everywhere is all of these
exotics not gonna break this thing is
this mobility thing gonna let you jump
up so many different things have to be
tested continually if they bring a new
exotic thing again that allows the Titan
to double - is he gonna be able to break
the map and get in this specific area
and that could end they have to test
every damn as a whole damn world as it
grows and they cannot keep doing that so
the bigger goes the sustainability of
just like maintaining everything still
functioning gets harder and harder so on
the other side he said seasons can do
some heavy lifting in a sense of giving
players a sense of a shared purpose of
what they're going for but when we ready
expansions it's a chance to make some
more fundamental changes that the game
war
and it's systems and they said we've
done significant system changes to all
destiny games every time we've shipped
in expansion armor armor 2.0 rain their
roles in forsaken artifacts and rise of
iron taking King game-changer back every
time it gets different and they say now
we're gonna be making more changes to
the game world as we go so this is a
prime example and then I just want you
to like plunder while I say this one
currently right now there's a ship that
can swallow planets parked outside of
necess you want to know what happens
when they talk about changing the game
world yeah
Nessus just got swallowed that crap is
gone we wanna see them here you want to
see the pyramid ships invade what if
every planet has crashed pyramid ships
and where those pyramid ships crash in
the veil are around defending that ship
and then like move lead sections of like
the European dead zone and Mars have a
completely different theme they've been
covered by the veil they're invading
like again games that have done it
before Cataclysm in World of Warcraft
they literally split the continents with
a crack in the earth like you're talking
hat like a continent which who you could
run from top to bottom which would take
you like an hour to get to the bottom if
you just like trotted on your horse like
the continent and just basically cut it
in half as something came out of like
the subterranean like split it lava like
every single zone completely changed
that's the type of thing I think they
want to try and get to so I mean whether
pyramid ships crash down and there's
invasions blowin stuff up before at a
race that wasn't a terrible movie min
but I mean that's the type of thing like
if we have the pyramid ship sitting on
the moon if that stuff comes in I want
the world to look completely different
if that crap invades like don't want to
sell everything changed I've been saved
but he wanted it huh that's a rest in
peace fail-safe no say on that say oh
yeah she done but in defense did say
got too many NPCs he did mention running
around you know there's a big cast out
without you don't saying so things are
gonna happen and I think we go this
steam mixer on they seem to have
listened to the last book and they just
love all this deletion talk oh this will
move will talk hey we're gonna get like
we're gonna call retiring of some things
because it's nomination as I was saying
so it's letting things retire and they
will not be useful in powerful stuff oh
that's what encouraged ow he's like I
think the idea of if they can't grow the
world I'd like to see them evolve it and
I think this is what they're going for
and honestly I'm very very intrigued
what they might be able to do personally
because if you take a world of any of
the planets we've seen for three years
and they want to maintain that at least
destiny to for maybe one or two more
years depending the world does need to
evolve or people are still going to be
looking at the same European dead zone
patrols for the 4th year and at some
point that's got to change
no so now the big giant topic that is
the can of worms that apparently I
opened last week didn't know and timing
is amazing though cuz like Friday we
joked we talked a little you and I
talked a little afterwards we were still
like and then this dropped and I was
reading through it I tweet I texted this
man four times while I was really good
four times so I'm gonna go back up to
Luke Smith interlude before we even get
into it I want to read this one tonight
nice low right evil evil abut indeed
okay so up in the seasons rocky had an
interlude he's like oh I don't want to
do weapons stuff now it's like there's
more later but let's turn the waters a
little bit he said I still I still
really like playing this game I've
acquired almost every weapon in the game
why anarchy apparently still missing
that one I have some pretty slick roles
on a few of them and some near-miss in
it approved god rules on others which I
love that he said that spare rations
he'll clip full-bore with a quick visit
to disappointment town with a leg
like many of you I end up gravitating to
a few weapons and just using them
instead of everything else
sure a la multi kill cut breach right
from season of dawn is nice to have and
I love the art for season of dawn but is
it really gonna replace my go-to PvE
kinetic weapon probably not I know that
I recently sat down with a couple of
external folks who loved breakneck I
said it's the only thing they use they
are never gonna use another primary in
destiny - why because they don't need to
learn part of aspiration is the pursuit
that comes with it and right now their
weight the way we are and have been
treating weapons investing - isn't
actually fueling ass but the aspiration
engine so that ties into this big topic
of weapons weapons forever the problem
hey continue going I'm just gonna open
the can of worms do you want me to just
TLDR this thing you want me to Kenny hit
the high alright he's like I was like
weapons right now basically every weapon
from dusty to vanilla every weapon you
get is a weapon you can keep infusing
and raise its power level indefinitely
in dusty - with infusion it's like
having every card you own in magic
available and playing on all formats
forever it passively creates power creep
an ongoing destiny problem which also
means our teams and this is one thing I
didn't even think about last time need
to spend more and more of their time
retesting and supporting old stuff
instead of making new stuff it reduces
it reduces player desire for new items
it it it means we ultimately create a
ton of gear that doesn't have any value
beyond taking the box I got it on the
checklist see that isn't value it's the
actually the opposite of value because
it's work that we could be putting into
making new stuff or improving old stuff
our comedy our combat team works
extremely hard and this is like this is
one thing it's hearing a little bit
later that like last time we talked
about it you absolutely nail this
our combat team works extremely hard to
make weapons feel unique each legendary
gets their own flavors and special sauce
sometimes it's the way a gun sounds and
this mentioned it last time like for me
when I picked up ask a flock and I fired
that first time I was like that that gun
is exactly what I thought it should be
it sounded right it like it fit the
theme in the weapon slightly military
not crazy in the future it just sounded
like that that gun sometimes it's
insanely over budget ranged and I don't
know what he is talking about hand in
hand to you is that like a gun or old
thing I don't remember sometimes that's
the real recoil pattern shadow to fall
out in shotguns because that's always
already sometimes it's the art like
Bastion is beautiful like there are so
many like I mean you take per outbreak
perfected whisper I mean there are so
many iconic weapons they're like the art
on some of these they're amazing right
sometimes it's something there's more
don't worry he mentioned a little bit
more later too
and he said sometimes it's something
indescribable that just makes an item
resonant with our players and that is
true like for me and this is where I
fall into the category of not desiring
as much new stuff because I do I haven't
as you said I have this attachment to my
go figure and a blast furnace is
technically a better gun I've used it
and if it had the role I wanted it would
probably be better be cut because like I
have been through so much I have so many
kills and I know I know myself how it
shoots I know how it feels I know what
I've done with it it's like my old
reliable and instead of trying that new
thing that even might be the same if not
better where I'm still gonna fall back
on my old reliable and it quite a few
people may do the same now not everybody
right but generally that's one of those
it's like you do get attached to some of
the weapons absolutely just what does
that nobody to do what are the
emphasized once again my whole thing
with I know you're making comparisons
lastly control of craft what they do in
reference to the needing to the time
right all our state is
these other gave her sponge is a master
of gunplay because bug keep our masters
of ordinance and artwork and feel and
sound right
that's why the level of attachment
greater than any other game because they
have the best the I was gonna say they
got the best come tight in my opinion
nothing feels that so when you couple
that with these beautifully designed
weapon right that's where that
ridiculous insane attack you thought
that's my thing that's my thing now
where I will say if you remember he this
back the last word the full left right I
said I couldn't eat with a compromise on
season one the better devil stop the
nameless midnight stuff I get that at
some point the loop pool becomes too big
right you gotta worry about
I get that where I was emphatic if you
remember what we talked about to less oh
I know you said exotics old Eddie we
gonna get to that so this was a weird
Bob because on one hand turtles like Dan
they listen to II I'm finished
oh they're gonna company eat this this
is gonna be awful but did when I saw any
exact some right oh I thought literally
when I saw your Edition tech and what
was highlighted you literally I'll be
brutally honest Asael SP buddy they
pushed it
I was I was seriously con not knowing me
I was yeah already does that
you know I've been kicking in scratch
you been but her for a little while I've
been but her I would have had to get out
of my feelings involve a kid something
cool happens and then the love stuff but
with a static
that met cook again kid
like I said laughing disrespect layer
engaged it whisper of the warm quest
what that did for the community I don't
break crap dude what am i destined dude
that I haven't even met in real life
these here at pact I'm gonna meet him
this week right dude showed up he's like
I said no way you had he's like us today
whatever you may had a Trevor shirt I
knew exactly what I get that connectable
weapon he put in the buzzer don't for
them to say we go take that away I
wasn't it literally below you why am I
playing your game because you're gonna
give me these great moments it's a hey
it's fine no more now go do something
else now Oh baby go brush my teeth but
it so that's where it was it was it was
really the exactly if I remember the
loudest I got was Telesto in whisper it
hurt let's go like you didn't go through
blood sweat and tears to get Telesto I
didn't but the thing about it I was
thinking about the time who's like me
who's like yo I love the weapon I need
the catalyst and remember those two
weapons that weapon in particular Lester
and sleeper those are gonna get all this
terrible raid they terrible raid to get
of BS average but if you love that guns
like the Patels doesn't be so much
better if I do this but let me grind it
out I'm in dude I am still for the
record in spire of stars
LF G's just so I could try to get the
sleeper cast it was simply kappa that's
how much I love you know it's nerve to
hell I have the best version of anyway
we got we kind of jumped through this
topic pretty class but he even said it
to is like I played mmo's I played
action RPGs where you get amazing
weapons and that's the thing but he
stated it's like rarely do those weapons
feel like an extension of my avatar and
that's what you described like that
connection to the weapon because you are
looking down at the until time that is
live through your weapons and it's like
they you get an attachment to like in
blood-borne your switch axe or insecure
Oh your katana is part of you as opposed
to a stat stick as he called something
probably from World of Warcraft because
it's like yeah I put it on my character
and has the best stats but I'm not
really paying attention to the fact that
it's a different slightly different
looking stick like that's the
differences like we do live and breathe
through these things and that's where
they get important so he goes back to a
little bit of saying and this is where
I'm gonna bring it around the weapons
vault of glass could be powerful unique
and a rare those were some of the most
like wildly sought-after
things if you had faint bringer you
probably had a bunch of a signet shards
to commemorate all the times you didn't
get it and all those times you
celebrated or hated when somebody else
got it but when you finally got that
thing it mattered but there was space in
the loop pool they knew things weren't
gonna last forever so if they built this
thing that was like capped at level 30
then when he went to go to the next
thing well I got to get something new to
be more powerful and they knew that
stuff would not live in trials and live
in these things for the forever there
was a a window on those there was a in
an expiration date per se where it
wouldn't continue to be there right and
they said currently in the version of
destiny it's hard to find space for some
new stuff we have so many or three years
into this game we're looking at four
maybe five who knows how long this thing
could be going and at some point
how long do you want to be able to use
your midnight coup in my newest raid and
that's and I've seen I have been like
commenting on Twitter just to like spark
fires I posted a video about today my
video comments they are probably
three-quarters just ripping that idea to
shreds they seriously are I mean there
are a lot of people that like why should
I even play the game if my thing has an
expiration should I haven't grind for
anything and I'm about the reasonable
one I don't understa hey if I compromise
keep your exotics right yeah I know
there are some that I like hell no I
better like I feel sorry
go for the Leviathan midnight coup
inaugural address those have been yeah
and that's the that that's the question
I keep continually asking everybody I
asked it last week and the general thing
is and some people just be like I want
to use my gun forever well guess what
it's probably not gonna happen but my
general idea is like how long do you
want to keep playing destiny too and
still be like yep midnight coup yeah at
one point do you do you what like how
long is that point where you're like I
should probably not be able to use that
anymore now if you say always then
you're just gonna have to swallow this
one because it's apparently gonna hurt
right but on the other side if they
saturate the loot pool so much that for
them to be able to try and design
another weapon and they do their best to
make these things unique right they
spend the time to make a unique sound a
firing rate an animation but how many
more thing I mean Bungie works to make
unique things but how many times can you
stack another 900 Auto rifle another 150
hand cannon and try and make it worth
your grind worth the difference if you
always have like well I've got a good
one 50m scrim pull that right yeah I
used it I completely get the monster all
I want to say the last point the
architect last was that you're right
from a pure technical standpoint I
understand the thing comes down to in my
opinion if funds let's play this way in
a perfect world if Bungie was still with
Activision hi moon blah blah blah
we have d3 right now I only believe now
because that situation changed that's
why we're in this position now I mean it
basically it's again we're not getting
deeply anytime soon so as a result the
way the annual parents factor in
introducing of Lulu and new and no new
game that's why we're here they realize
everyone's
right to your point they add new gun is
it really good that they add a new hope
is it really gonna be better than dad
bought you I'm saying bygones or dad buy
at some point you have too many stimula
archetype and you just go to reserve
back everything you're seeing is like
the reason why it Dharan because this
length of time should have now been the
deep part where we have blown up or
whatever maybe and then we wouldn't have
to painful move no one was expecting
this pain cuz this is right around new
dancer so now we gain this is the new
way right now the question I have for
you okay is the time a lot now for my
understanding they were saying what nine
nine fifteen months okay don't let's
let's break that down but I think is now
it's like stale milk everything got an
expiration date court didn't Bacchus me
right don't do our law - you've got a
new go speed that I followed that he
listed if I do it I will next time I'm
with you I'll column just so you can say
hello
clearly you went to a Bundy summit that
I was hundred percent you have there's
so much sarcasm for you audio listeners
by the way you have no idea the funniest
loss of an arm yet I've had birthday
because literally who next week the man
as I know everything you have to say
we're doing everything we listen to the
brand from now on Bunji of artists gonna
sign the table next to Cosmo I'm gonna
look over and put my part yeah so anyway
my question to folks decide how do you
handle the effort do I get my legendary
since we became Insider you
when I get to eat when I get the gun
does it have like a you know due date by
like I just like that's gonna probably
my guess is they have to plan out the
power crime now the way the seasons work
right now the tintin tintin whole thing
I'm kind of hoping that changes in year
four as well because I think that's
something they're probably thinking
about cuz the way it works right now the
pinnacle grind is honestly a three month
yeah and especially them taking away the
artifact for PvP enabled trials that's
even more may so I'm hoping that changes
to either a bigger number something
different going forward but honestly if
they can plan that out and kind of agree
on it I would say you wouldn't see a
date you would probably say it might as
you hover over infusion you might have a
little tooltip saying max infusion
eleven hundred something like that your
area sorry no one is disagreeing that
yes technically it's basically not gonna
be able to get yes they do exist right
but let's be real here this was the same
thing like icebreaker back in the day
well they wouldn't let you be able to do
to go Wow
but guess what people did they stood
there and they jump in the Sun activity
right and still tried to use those
old-school guns that was overpower for
service that you made this to try to get
by so that nasty community is we ate it
now granted Oh beautiful active its
doctor you're gonna get murked
well that's why it's especially if it's
that nine to twelve months you'll have
an expansion that expansion has to have
like a 203 power level 2 or 300 level
power level jump yeah so that Delta of a
hundred is far blown away so like if you
take that into the new stuff well you
are definitely going in at a massive
detriment that you're not gonna do much
they have to set they have to set the
expansion and that level jump far enough
and big enough that less you can't even
try right now we're going around on
patrols can you go a basic quick play
match sure
come down to the night portal you
absence the rains the new content
permissible and in that sense it's you
don't there so I do it I just wanted to
be clear about that party good to you
but you were saying you would still have
a date you think I would never date if
they if they can figure out like maybe
one or two years however long does need
to is gonna last and be like okay so
four year for its fifty fifty fifty and
say when September comes out what are we
gonna be up to cuz this one we're going
979 eighty is that right yeah be nine
eighty nine ninety well so then we'd be
touchin near a thousand then September
needs to be like twelve fifty yeah you
need to go like two hundred some odd
power levels up so if you and try and
take that into like current content you
are gonna be shooting peanuts like it
needs to be enough to where you're like
I'm not hitting them oh I can't hit them
that's why but shout out the house daddy
he said he wonders what this means for
virtual weapons they can put the
exploration on on that crap right I came
that thing them them don't ones that
they gave us Python
Komodo those three yeah you think you
think now of what you got in like the
VEX offensive weapons probably not gonna
be infused in September but right now
you're looking at nine months maybe
you're dawn stuff will carry into
September but maybe that's it for that
season I mean that he I would probably
count on roughly a year that would be my
hunch the nine months is where you
picture season have gone to an expansion
when that expansion comes we out we
going next but that three months but but
that three months before you can't
nullify that so the next season
depending there trying not to nullify it
too quickly right look why would be okay
with it but again no I think wrap I
think I think recluse is getting stale
milk oh yeah no I mean I think oh those
are gonna be old yeah they're all going
yeah it was a pinnacle mountain top
recluse all that stuff is so old it's
gonna be outside of a year pinnacles
aren't gonna be
you're not gonna have pinnacle you're
not gonna have a clue sand raids no
mountaintops and that will change all
those strategies and that's the thing
they saw or Legendary's right now they
may do this later on with exotics I know
I'm don't get me I was like you I was
like you may as well start getting ready
to swallow that we got three years this
is you know how like you have your
parents when they they try to force you
taking medicine them say no and then
like they kind of sneaky to you this is
easy into it and again picture like at
some point whisper gets retired I you
know I have more attachment to that gun
than most of you guys do you have any
idea how much time I spent in that
mission now this is why take heavy
sniper rifles you have Darcy you have
whisper and Izanagi doesn't count but it
may as well but those two heavy snipers
can they make another heavy sniper right
now fight fight win there again as they
keep making weapons with perks and
exotics and it keeps being saturated
take a weapon type pick one specific one
how many different ways can you make
variety and again if whisper fades away
like going into year five you can you
could get the quest but but that gun has
a lifespan of like three and a half
years it had a great run we doin not a
15-month is up at some point I could see
it yo eat yo Luke Smith stop listening
to the fine again
stop listening to this look I'm trying
to get over orchard if you put hey
exotics aren't happening right now you
can just you can enjoy him for as long
as you read and your even corruption
among nobody listed and now you come in
for my eggs how dare you
how do you know know know
hashtag save the gun come on y'all
yeah yeah exotic side here this will be
were saying eventually it will probably
happen so they can continue to make new
exotics what is the point of the quest
exotic thing time and how long did you
get to enjoy that the nerve to say hi
you harpy rien nothing lasts forever so
why play the game why play if every gt-r
you're gonna press the button what is
the bow oh thank you areas by the way
I'm areas is like fighting for me in
chat man this is amazing
ok no Johnny's six onyx I'd like to or
it depends on how long destiny lasts
now if destiny ends at year for in year
five honestly probably they won't mess
with if it's year four and they're like
art we got d3 coming out 2022 we got one
more year we gotta get three seasons
probably not if destiny to is truly
where they have if they like if they
completely do a game changer in destiny
to is like they take destiny three and
shove it into destiny to then I see the
exotics being like retired and sunset
off the light there yeah that back is
gonna be the Camelback right they're not
getting away with this legendary right
now but I'm telling you right just pull
in there
could you imagine let me paint a picture
psychopath I've been through whatever
you're about you whip up I've already
done it playing d1 and the magic that
gap all you heard about the legend did
gap this literally happened in taking
away now you got happen because
coming up that's one year one gel horn
is released like a few weeks before from
xur people buy it and you don't take a
king and you can't take it forward new
game came out and imagine just that
everyone said oh my god
finally and then next week guys this is
the cutoff yes that is how what is held
that goes tell me no that's how Wow go
this thing Wow bro
that is how that is how an evolving game
continues very fresh and involve a gun
gay realize this right this is sure guns
in this no no I've been running around
poking people with my fingers for five
years this is my fist
I've been fist down people for five
years that sounds a lot worse than I
thought it would there is like when when
infusion didn't get started that's
exactly what happened you got it in last
three weeks three weeks later taking
home attack W cross Scott
this is that bottom lip stop comparing
don't listen or let's that's cute that's
you I understand they have variety it's
a game but you tell let's be real that I
should have much it is it
this is preference I don't know what a
disrespect track if you like or less
good you just what
let us talk about engagement how many
people are still engaging with more
layers the way they engage this is a
reason because you have the emotional
attachment to the gun yep it can't I
can't
well I don't see people naming these
even other games that try to do in fact
real division and thumb they don't do it
side and let let me ask you this Taylor
you know nobody does exotics how best do
with that ATT could try to fight the
but it's never replicated to this level
of emotional attachment stop America
talking not comparing them or other
games they don't have the greatest
gunplay thank SD that that five people
Oliver
you see the message boards you see how
crazy what do that exotic thing do that
exact thing with God what you take it
with you
wait till you see them left what do you
see ready what do you read it we got we
got hit all right bye bye whisper hey
what's the let me a minute let me ask
you this exotics can come forward but
the Leviathan leaves the solar system
you can't go get your catalyst now make
you know that is that is a big moving
that is rabbit only I just believe the
narrative forward I'm saying get rid of
graviton lands I could still get the
cameras that you can still use the gun
and basic stuff you just can't use it
pinnacle stuff you actually get like you
get it better than like most other games
that like you level up you get an
expansion you're more powerful than your
old stuff you don't use it anymore you
can still use it in your basic events I
can go pull my whisper out for 17 years
we're not really what's the percentage
of his body there's a lot of them at
this point why can't we we work exact
huh why can't we sit there and say you
know what why is reworking exotic when
you can make a new one what the goodness
nothing at the end of the day
would you rather would you rather be
like hey this thing that was in my
inventory in my collections I'm sorry
because you're not keeping them in your
vault that's been there for two years
oh it got reworked hey this thing got
retired I'm not really gonna pull any
more but I got this new drop which is
better what's the value of chasing
exotics if they're only to go way at a
year maybe they have a longer lifespan
maybe they're twice as long who is going
to want to grind cattle it and heart
content and race you can use it by two
years because you can use it for two
years and then there's a point guess
what
that
you've had for two years isn't coming
with you into the next raid because it's
just seen some work and it's it's
finally busted it finally got used to my
player engage no not yet
with disrespect and playing English see
this point when you talk about respect
it is like best things again want me to
go jump through fire oh but you're gonna
take this away keep that up for you keep
that and watch what happens
what trust me that's a decimal I yeah I
can stay all this cool stuff all you
want in this game with guns batter and
artwork and design and some of the best
in gaming this is your trump card of why
your game is the death you are now going
to take that away any disrespect put it
against me
rough watch what happens is it I'll tell
you that that's the death keep that up
Lucy will see well I watch ready all
right ready it's right now a flaming
wrong now I don't have no one actually
defending it's like they're blaming you
guys go go go go check it out see what's
going on out there
you see I'm halfway with you in statics
is my bra it'll be hard to login I'm
finished Larry I thought I was but you
got me going you got no it's gonna
happen the length of Destiny to will
determine if exotics happen if it's four
years in deep okay so if you get d3 none
of it matters all the stuff I played for
four years I invested thousands of hours
that get this catalyst do you hurry all
gone
you've given me a new game you give me
better graphics dedicated servers hold
and play a gazer across but you've given
me so if you're gonna take from the
player you have to give something back
it's only right that it 16 you wanna
play that is an entitled mentality but
I'm paying you to play your life hey I'm
a Live service game you said it right
there
elihue everybody who come to me which
are handout for $10 every cent every
handout for 30 hours did you say for 30
that I paid
you're taking my guns away didn't I yeah
brah no hundred percent no Aries no
sorry there get there they want to give
you new guns I pay for that gun why I
keep cuz it doesn't work anymore cuz it
doesn't work in you can you still have
it and you all have it what it's not
powerful they devoted a ghost or he
comes yeah I want to see your face when
someone comes in your house and say yo
it's okay don't even try that this is a
video game that doesn't even compare
have a real argument this is the point
and you said it and that was the perfect
word and I'm glad you did it is a Live
service game
yes Crips in the game pass that I'm
paying for oh they just took a game away
okay same thing what the here's the
difference you know that with big game
passes out and keep it have the option
to keep it that can every necklace if it
goes out the step I could keep this okay
well what about Netflix it's alive sir
the thingy height anybody who has an
issue with this argument the idea is the
game wants to evolve bunchy wants to
continue to evolve this and if we keep
hanging on to [ __ ]
and I'm gonna say it now cuz its after
about 11 o'clock at night if you guys
want to keep hanging on a [ __ ] that is
four years old and has been through a
thousand bullies who made someone go
through hoops for anything in it who men
even go through hoops so it's that
apples to a picture picture picture any
not even world picture any subscription
type thing any subscription MMO but it's
not what are you working hard to to
accomplish by watching your neck that's
going away nothingness I'm trying to
give you live service examples of things
that do not last forever nothing
ever ooh but the point is there's no
there's a difference between those life
services and again there's no work
involved to obtaining it's not like when
you launch destiny the exotics jump out
the screen it's not like they let you
have all that you have to earn it
there's no earning in necklace okay fine
they say that flexaway are we're gonna
go back to your tell me you don't have
to earn anything in a game like World of
Warcraft that's the game you're using
that the game that act no but I'm just
saying if you want to talk about
something with a time investment
something you have to earn something
that is valuable to your character now
it may have been a two-year cycle so
take your exotics on the same thing when
a massive expansion came out and they a
rift cracked in the middle of the world
and now you can go from level 60 to
level 70 or level 70 to level 80 that
amazing stuff that you spent hours and
hours in literally I had 40 days on
characters of rating that stuff at level
70 when you hit level 71 you just
literally got better stuff and that old
stone there then how can you understand
that you cannot get on board with the
other it's the same price again it goes
back to what I said
what makes destiny great but this isn't
living in the past
come on you games okay here I'm just
gonna ask you this right now destiny now
is gonna last 20 years long do you want
to use whit do you want to be able to
pull Whisperer out in the year in the
year 20 raid how do I have to say okay
we need dud no no this is my this is my
art this is gonna stick with this
argument because this is how long if
destiny to d3 doesn't exist it is gonna
be shoved into destiny too and destiny 3
that's where we are so destiny 2 is
gonna last for the next 6 years right
that's what we have now you year 6 that
raid Whisperer should still be allowed
to come to that raid at full power
by your sick you should be big about it
today what if they evolve what if they
have all destiny - you're gonna get if
they in cross play if they switch they
like start moving solar system planets
Leviathan eats nessus we get said all of
those things evolve and you're telling
me whisper should still come to that
next raid I'm trying let me show you why
let me tell you why I like it based on
the technical limitations of what they
just said right now they're at home
obviously they're at capacity but
they're at a point where they can't keep
adding things all the country parties
that that's why I'm saying take that
argument and set it aside
say yes because that's just the reason
why it just in your life so give this
evolving world right will you're adding
doing things busy there's a stealing
there's a limit to how much you can add
before you reach max capacity which then
goes then hang that statement and a plan
to the weapons
what because at that point why not do
the whole group thing together right
we're at max capacity with the weapon
we're at saturation with the move to
your right
saturation now everything is do much how
many whispers run it around five snipers
going around I get what you're saying
do a lot of thing is this is a unique
situation because they have to extend a
little bit more that's we're gettin I
get it I'm accepting that right what the
next six bro I want a game you can't
keep beating okay but yes they take the
technical piece out of it for a second
remove that and just imagine they
actually are capable imagine they find a
way to take the ideas they want for d3
the pyramid ships come in Saturn is a
new thing Nessus gets swallowed by
Leviathan and callused drives away so
you got a new planet that I'm literally
there's no one she ate out there cuz it
could have already you have Mars rest
mutant blows up what's another planet I
can't think uh Rasputin blows up I oh ok
well now we have access we're reaching a
little farther one of Saturn's moons
we're going to Europa so what director
keeps evolving this is something they
potentially could do I'm not
this is what's gonna happen I'm trying
to get to the end of this timeline for
you well we continue to do this in d3
and they're phasing out the legendaries
but these exotics they're still sitting
there
oh we're already here six and in year
six this raid comes out and snipers are
in a pretty good spot you want to still
be able to go you pull your little year
one whisper the worm and take it into
the year six rate I don't I said set
that aside because your argument is you
want exotics to last until d3 well I
guess I do right I do my thing is again
between beating anyone who's in the chat
pull up the year that d1 came out in
full up to here with these big there's
good Tiki tane
there's 2014 2017 well how many is that
it's three okay
we've reached a common grade ground now
this is what I'm talking about
No okay I'm saying I understand the time
window I'm saying take that aside they
are by themselves they do not have
Activision they may not have get what if
they grow wait so then what their
capacity is not destiny three what if
the asset is to invest in you to buy
them so right with this bandwidth with
the day right I'm saying we can go four
to five right what a five we could go
you know I'm saying I'm with you on that
and then you gotta do the cup boost
actually can't create what I'm glitching
with that all I was doing but at four to
five we better start announcing the new
game that's all I'm saying
why can't I have a new game at that
that's not my argument you are stepping
away from my question I keep asking you
technical limitations of another game
aside within destiny - how long do
exotics last what is your numbers at
three years four years five years twenty
years
isn't there a number to me it's it's not
it's that a static question like it's
really I kicked a static answer to a
year on when I should I can't
if that that because my whole answer
with exotics is tied to the next game
that's why I can't you do a static
answer yes and that's why I keep asking
you what if there if there wasn't one
yeah you know yeah I know you want one I
know what everybody who is out there
expects d3 at some point but I'm trying
to get this point through your head you
know there is no d3 just a save game
forever for seven years
you look like d2 to 2022 really you
think that's gonna happen
really what if they're capable of
evolving I'm not buying that Dad not
buying that all that weakens we could
play this old game is great we're not
playing that you acted like this is like
some small little indie team the white
board said year 4 year 5 year six year
seven it does not say year for d3 right
right now because they just separated
but we're talking about here seven of
destiny - what if I actually lasted that
long
oh let's keep the anxiety then let's go
you're going seven years on whisper the
- yes yes and okay that's all right I'm
or net don't get rid of B that's the
book value thing but you're telling me
at some point in exotic shouldn't be
retired in seven years
yes no retirement of exotics that is
tied to that title that was the question
I was trying to ask you ten minutes all
at least I know are you saying they
retired gala for Andy to start it think
you could do your retirement that is the
most valuable piece of content in the
game no do not do that
I'm sorry I'm fighting on now I'm dying
on it I'm dying on oh yeah
he started system on value will pay you
just in my opinion that's just be made
everyone else's reasons you listen to
this and can we interview one of you
guys I would love to know some questions
anyways I finally got my answer so if
you would ask a question we could have
moved on but you wouldn't answer my
question
that's what I kept trying to ask you for
like 15 minutes if you want but it's not
really started that whole question with
hey this probably isn't gonna happen but
if it did because it's a hypothetical
trying to figure out how long you want
to hold on to this old crap and you
finally they mean answer it yeah if it's
really that a static answer I thought it
really it wasn't like I can give you
like okay five it really not it doesn't
work that way but that's but there but
if they want to make it at continually
involving their literal mission
statement bungees to make this an
ever-evolving living world if that
living world still has a to one its four
more years from now whisper still is
there yeah
Wow see we've got gonna paint this
narrative that Christopher is holding
back
well you've got all these dillion's of
wizards Lester every crew all of those
that have the game will be zillions of
guns in a legendary that you're taking a
retiree that bears your answer that
means that there's guns in that
archetype that's going out so if those
are brought out why we gotta destroy the
exotic let's stop there why did science
gotta go if there's a small percentage
in each archetype right
there's no you're getting the majority
of the drugs already you've already won
II know getting the majority of the guns
in the game that's the majority do the
percentages exotics are not the majority
and they're rare and they're hard to get
and you make it work for them that's my
point
I'm not I'm dying on it I don't care how
long it is you can't do that that's just
my opinion of how I feel about getting
many that feel as strongly as I do it
Twitter I'll get ready I'm just telling
them I'm not alone on this
not a chat kappa crazy old man dies what
is it Alex fine I'll be that I'll be to
do out I'll take one for the exact team
exact put a cactus at some point does it
not get does it no feel like there's a
refreshment required nope
feels amazing when I look at that
whisper to what I know what I did I know
the date I did it was like D I'm not one
of them have to have it in the game to
remember everything you did with it you
know you would you lived it unless your
memory sucks you know you did it well
why did why you have to take it away why
are you coming in like the woman because
four years old it's because it's three
and four years old and won't on two
other planets have that emotional
attachment but me and a little [ __ ] on
whisper of the worm you and I have
emotional attachment you know just my
royal ass right now I attack when I
watched your video you made that amazing
what's gonna happen take a poll I'm
gonna tell you right now what about your
blood sweat tears for your video that
you made giving people rookies and all
the people that had no problem to get
that gun making those jokes oh your
videos no you could delete your you
teacher what's the purpose how to be a
project creator do you humpin all these
people make these exams do these and
then it don't exist the law no no no
YouTube video you expect to have a lot
of views
two years later much less you're talking
about seven no way do I expect a YouTube
video seven years from now people like
hey I wanna go get my exotic from year
one destiny hey Bonta says this video
from seven years ago that's why I has a
very raw people still wouldn't want to
know how to do these things and I didn't
say two or three I'm trying to make it
extreme to make you pick a number but
you're cool with it be in there for
seven that was why you're gonna sit here
and like contradict yourself on like
well sevens like kind of ridiculous but
you just said you would take it for
seven what that's the part I want as
long as it sounds I would yeah I
literally made the content because it's
relevant at the time I'm not gonna go
make Khan
unlike the value of your and your
continuity found in there's no reason
for it and literally whatever every
YouTube person to put content puts
content out there is devalued the minute
it's out there are you telling me your
iron Lords podcast from six months ago
have the value that they'd added not an
instructional guide you can't make the
app it's it's time relevant content what
my dessert sir is null and void every
single week Nursultan every zur video is
no avoiding me for days
Aaron videos out of age I did my Tuesday
weekly reset my nightfall guides are not
useful a week later you comparing that
to getting the world it's the same do
you want to know how much time I put
into some of those nightfall guides
probably about the same amount of time I
put in that whisper oh yeah okay so that
whispered attraction and I you know my
youtube I know my YouTube content
doesn't live forever I'm fully aware if
my content live forever with my what
forever gila honest do you honestly in
your heart is your whisper video has the
same exact value as you're in your mid
swimwear come on right now my serve
videos get more than my whisper come on
you that answer together to a man with
the model put in your wish which is the
no those aren't the same but that's not
that's not a comparison my serve video
no my serve video does not live miser
video doesn't live forever and my
whisper guy doesn't live in is my
question that's not my question
the live forever is not my question to a
man is that video of the wisp all more
value to you then your serve video
honestly well of course it does snake
why does it well it's my biggest video
of all time
hey that me but it's not gonna live
forever
I'm not gonna live ever ever ask Laura
no we're not because I'm helping we're
never gonna get to the table I'm help
we're never gonna get I'm gonna have the
kind of help you understand the mindset
of a person who wants to keep feedback
right all I'm saying is I don't want to
another ever attached to that video
that's made to me when you made the
video yes and that is a memory that's
not something that lives forever
that's not the myth though our usual
positives but I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to help you understand you
try to be now you try to die and I
respect that when you know in your heart
in your heart what that video done
that's all the people that love eggs are
saved that's all we're trying to say in
our heart that's what those needs are
that's what I am aware of that but that
video does not have a lifespan of seven
years that video has had has trickled
long because a few people still go and
look at it but that video had a peak it
fell off and it mostly was done now it
has like dribbler along you you can you
can move forward matters in the sense
how you doing man what's up brother you
could do better than me with in terms of
letting those dog and I'll give you that
and all I'm saying is a security who
feel just like these are the reasons in
their minds they play death for those
moment that's the for a lot of people is
a moment game what where were you act
will you did it
who were you with what we did that's
what destiny so a lot of people grow in
those moments fair enough that's all we
get it we let's move on are we both down
a step I get it yeah I just we're gonna
agree to
because this ain't ever happened we do
watch we got stopped yes sir yeah -
outstanding this question do I think the
weapons stuff would have happened if
trials wasn't coming next season into
some of the people that I've talked to
it's been something that's been on the
back burner for a little hour period I
get the last ever is that about 40 I
said exotic take the legendaries I'm
been in the O net I don't like that e
but you're just saying something still
has to last forever is the hill you are
technically dying on it's like not
everything but something lasts forever
nothing lasts forever mostly and all I'm
saying did you take it if you want it to
last forever go take a screenshot of
that thing put it in your wallpaper just
like a photograph in real life I'm not
seeing the new baby that's not forever I
can't say that I don't ever want them to
go take it away when you give you a new
pool that's not forever so please don't
put the work forever with me that's not
what I'm saying
but if there it but you will still live
on that whole seven years if destiny
lasted that long technical like
separation aside you would still keep it
in there that long and that is a
long-ass time it's clearly bothering you
guys in the development of the small
percentage of guns in the game disagree
anyway I believe that horse is
officially dead yes all right if
everybody's got a shake out their eyes
and ears and kids are grown up already
delete those fish anyway so we did
actually get a 12 it was a late one
because I guess they were looking over
it for a while as opposed to like a
couple hours ago two or three something
like that it was nuts posted four hours
ago so it was up but but it was late I
was like 7:30 8 o'clock my time we have
some sub Club I'll let you talk for a
while because I feel like yes Bobby I
don't want a warmer minute all moving
well next year oh yeah yeah
I feel like I need a shirt made for this
or you need some time I don't annoy this
me I can't talk to this man I'm shutting
it down
I'm sure Bobby let's get ready we're at
two hours already
oh yeah we two out we go flaps changes
what I'm sorry I got the field itself oh
yeah pretty much the dev team comes out
he says hey we got the combats we've
been hard at work they want to talk
about all the data scientists and things
that they do to school per minute and so
on and so forth but we've all just
jumped right into the right so pretty
much these are the things that they
allocated their tape and they said this
is what we got look at the Warlocks the
stand up y'all cause y'all up on the
dock
so what mainly the Warlocks have moving
at a disadvantage it really takes
slightly longer the Titans are going to
feel a couple make the move it from next
season
baby the Warlocks basic melee prey to a
total of five 45 meters Morlocks you
know slightly things like Manning was
trying to score with another class from
they'll now have the 1 meter event you
just move on to land the first week
melee attack black pike you will emerge
victorious they feel this the more
interesting solution the many disparity
within the homogenizing or the melee
attack I've been studying the data and
opposing but make sure now Roman attack
height you barricade and we'll talk
about why not leave it go for it I'm in
warlock melee you can talk about no I
listen I we've been at a disadvantage
for a while you know um I think it's a
fair chain I kind of like this per se
they didn't eat it up to say end it now
extending is it advantage yes it is it
is an available and in the first one I
don't think my guess is like if you get
the first slap by a range I don't think
the time to get my second one off is
gonna beat you because he literally just
said if you are at the
you land up first you're gonna win the
second owner for punching out right you
literally just gave warlocks an
advantage
now indeed one warlocks I believe had
this um defendant ready they that's why
they were this reserve because they had
plate and they're giving it back the
difference this died still hit fast so
if we're at the same distance right yeah
jump on you I'm gonna win but if you
build a radius jump on me right but if
we still we had the slower advantage so
we're in my life above what do we both
do to stay with the slowest melee from I
was rocking I would rather see this be
equal on mail is I don't think melees
need to be like different between
classes now actually I think what the
issue really is and the fact that the
wall I can't wait wait but a lot of here
it's just the animation speed yeah I
think this is a technical issue that
they can't something must be really
honest if I make all the evidence each
thing yeah I mean that's that's logical
but it's like the animation speed must
be too long or yeah so we'll see how it
plays I'm not gonna get first yeah I can
take from me obviously ability despair I
prefer this but I got to see how it
plays on its bit that's all i guys so we
got next up tighten barricades yeah so
they said tighten barricade is
incredibly powerful in trials mostly due
to the resurrection of your fellow
teammates next season we're creating
counters to the barricade which while
also raising its health from 500 to 600
hit points barricades will now take
extra damage from special ammo weapons
anti barrier weapons and certain heavy
weapons this change to make barricade
sturdier while giving opposing players
options use their special able to bring
down barricades more quickly so the
following weapons do 30% extra to
barricade snipers grenade launchers
linear fusions machine guns traces and
anti barrier weapons the following to
sixty percent extra
fusions and shot ease oh you're gonna
want to pop a barrier up if you want to
go for a res but if you shooting them
with peanuts not gonna really do that
much they're gonna last even longer but
if you have a right weapon you're gonna
be able to drop them faster 60% damage
on a fusion rifle
that thing is gonna get melted yeah
people are running fusion those barriers
are gonna drop and that's one of those
things oh and plane Titans I might need
to switch to a fusion rifle so they're
gonna make you kind of have to adapt
depending on the class right and this to
me is clearly our trial because the
first thing was going to happen to a
trial start hey man go down if you're
tight you putting that barricade up
watch so they have to figure out a way
to come back that again
a lot of these vows old you're told that
was gonna happen people that oh the men
of the minute they're going to change
the meta a lot of this is we don't crowd
tell me I don't know yeah oh yeah uh so
next one is one shot abilities this is
Ben oh this is let me get you one
because I know this is big oh no the big
one is the handle arrived about that one
a lot so right okay finally finally it's
getting some I am not the only one high
and health supernova is busted yeah you
can go
we're starting with hunters anyway so
the throwing build oh yeah it looks like
he's taking a class at it shot him do
them this back there we looked at the
hunter obviously with the one-hit kill
they said Ben we're gonna learn
something people me to put all right
well the Titans each told the class abou
we've reduced the auto targeting angle
by 50% that might sound like a lot but
acrobatic Titans we could previously
auto car make an instant 90-degree turn
we've also adjusted the lunge distance
the five forty five meters for both
targeted in untargeted monthly call that
it lunges were previously stick while
untargeted lunges with previously 4.5
wheel these changes make for more
specifics on lunch for the hunters great
at night with each its tracking a
significant and Queen Anne you've seen
what that thing can do yes this piece
and reduce back
big the night movie and then global
Hawks head held supernova ease favorite
we've made another change to bring us
the billion line up with part of the
head or supernova strength by the return
particle and that's gonna also be to
those do they do that that's gonna get
some type of our data indicated it each
day even without controversy and help
supernova needed here are the team
increased activation time I feel point
six up reduce whole time you can't hold
around for from blip out reduce brain by
twenty Kristin Titan horizontal spread
of the boat actually father both
explosion now that's damage interesting
reducible exploding you talk a little
louder by the way you like trying to be
quiet yeah I'll be out I don't know I
can tackle the letter yeah i cool in all
place testing we found that the product
of these changes nobility but now has a
risk reward ratio met mental it out
after all distinct and vaporize
no kidding you don't say you could work
out a team sitting on a point with that
damn thing and it's one handheld nova
the discuss then even after a big
disgusting or is asked across would say
it's nasty yes type in nasty it's about
to be less of the bolts leads the more
concentrated damage at range this is the
silver line item of the both we can work
out pretty damage at brain improving
it's liability against the compensated
estate here's my part other elements of
the middle boy back walker path of the
pop included the no Cooper which now has
it hysterical mystic a longer duration
and everything
get what Titan where are you at with all
of it well I feel like the shoulder
charge already got some weird issues
because yeah the autotargeting going
down I already feel like it's low
because I've straight-up whiffed
shoulder surges now I know some people
hate the 90-degree turn and honestly
like that's a fair change shouldn't be
able to do that I'm honestly hoping some
of the targeting and untargeted I just I
feel like if I'm like relatively near a
person and I'm like looking at them and
I've got the shoulder charge fairly
lined up that I should actually hit
because I've missed some that I feel
like should honestly I'm glad this deter
of all it's full that's all this move
around hand out supernova it was worse
dad run around in that no skill at least
I got a hold in charge and have it this
joy it want to hold you could hold it
for four seconds around the corner and
then spray a cone Tassimo told people
hey you just run it let me crash into
somebody get into you ha
anyway I'm like I can't get to you with
your supernova you melt me and before I
get there definitely I can't hold my
indepth it well that's a radar you know
when somebody's nearby would begin to
yield
anyway a handheld reduced rate okay look
how many changes were done to mine and
look at all the list of stuff that was
done to yours yeah which one needed more
of the tweaks I would say the bullet
list says it all
it give more time I would give it can
multi kill from range and you hold it
and you get damage resistance with
controversal
do I just need to keep talking no but
you can't act like it's that any steel
ball with that composed you running
around a map like a psychopath and just
meaning someone point insta-kill in
depth that's that still based very
minimal skills required when that charge
time is so fast I have been running
around that corner they turn in short
and they turn in super me supernova me
there is very little they're like oh
it's coming let me charge here he is BAM
at least have to go to you you just sit
there and wait and iced it could I hold
it indefinitely look at wait no but you
know what I mean
I never said you could but you don't
have to you have raised you have your
charge time your charge time allows you
to charge it and throw it while I'm
running it - and I can charge it
indefinitely so I can wait but getting
back to you have a range in front of you
that it will fire so it's like oh you're
getting closer charge number eight it
goes away aware of how I have tried it
yes I am fully aware of that supernova
is broken and it's gonna hopefully be
less not all don't act like there's no
skill in ball compared to your damn
psychopath II know how many times you
know how easy it is to shut me down
oh well shotgun fusion oh I have to get
my melee range until I have to get melee
range to you I don't know what the range
on yours but they're reducing it by 20%
and it's still gonna hit from distance I
have to get within melee range if you
die to my shoulder charge either I get
you in the back which I could kill you
with a shotgun anyway or I'm running
around the corner and guess what you
shouldn't be around the corner anymore
than you should if you had a shotgun
that you are KP at D but I'm gonna let
this handheld supernovas been Horst and
shoulder charge had 100% yeah
well he needed to get both needed it's a
separate are happy but yes they're
getting tweaked and your supers getting
buffed which is fitting because I feel
that was a whole week so that's good
good I just
real quick why the hell if it would be
this it's funny about all the Nova war
it's going through so many to matter
it's like rollercoaster yeah they can't
that they can't decide it's too strong
it's too weak it's too strong it's too
weak what what is it
we don't know all right so general
subclass tuning we made changes to a
number of subclass pass an effort to
tighten the gameplay bounce
for example stormcaller top striker
bottom and arch starter bottom have
remained dominant in PvP for multiple
seasons and this is again where you have
to wonder it's been dominant for
multiple seasons so you guys know it's
been dominant for multiple seasons but
didn't feel like touching it I mean guys
come on give them a good pass seven
years consistently beating out all other
paths in both win rate and average
efficiency they actually talked early up
they talked about how much data they
have about what players win like is it
perception versus reality the number of
wins the time to kill the number of
weapons like the data they have is
insanity their data scientists have a
lot to dig through these paths have also
ranked them on the top among PvE paths
in terms of kills per minute which is
weird I don't picture
I know top tree like storm caller Bhadra
tree striker I could see some of those
but little picture arts traders being
like broken and being yeah I'm like I go
hammers I go I don't picture those as
killer in PvE so weird well we've
adjusted these paths and others to bring
them closer to the middle of PEC on the
other end of the past spectrum past such
as voidwalker bottom Night Stalker
bottom and striker middle because the
striker missile the flying human missile
thing nobody touches that thing in PvE
it's like I'll cool one shot we've taken
steps to lift them up in the spirit of
transparency we take no joy nerfing the
abilities weapons and armor that we all
love to use just remember this when you
talked about our weapons we wish to
answer keeping a game balanced and fresh
we always to buff the underpowered
elements but such an approach but such
an approach leads to power creep and
they talked about creeping weapons again
using their lords
oh yeah the slow and steady increase of
the average power of everything of the
game which trivializes the incredible
game modes and encounters that the other
teams at Bungie work to put together
after all destiny players ourselves you
want to go home and play the game too
and want the game to be as fun and
healthy as possible so that's most of it
from them
oh yeah 100 tripmines are sticky again
that's a good change I always enjoyed
those I don't even play a hunter though
should of things have never been not
sticky we've got some twitch Prime
Awards link your twitch account to
Bungie account go to Amanda holiday she
at least has something for you go get
some cosmetics if you didn't get suros
by two days ago then you missed it sorry
uh they said upcoming resolved issues
they've got some stuff coming up 410
travel loading times will be returned or
God just in time for you to be done turn
into your fractal lines what's not
matter do that well you'll notice uh
yeah that's the big one
it I don't know if you experienced to
eat it's been really bad there was one
time I actually left out food did almost
up a PC
I still what I'm talking about the tower
loading Ivan expel their humble yeah I
finally it started it again with what oh
yeah there they've been really bad they
were really bad on fractal line night
know when to go load in I think I went
to go get it was like console loading
times I may as well go get some food
make some dinner there's a couple things
there's some couple other patch notes
and stuff and there's a couple videos
they said it's been an eventful week no
kidding and we've shared a lot but we
aren't done yet
all this trials of Cyrus talk may have
some of you wondering if there's gonna
be PvE content coming next season Luke
mentioned we have more info coming and
shared a cool picture of net seasons
artifact so Luke seasons picture that he
tweeted which is kind of like the
concept art is like the war mind sword
yes
that's apparently gonna be our artifact
so that's kind of cool so war mind
sword thing going through an tabret or
Osiris or rest butan either way artifact
is gonna be coming through Mars would be
a guest
there's a fork a picture of it out there
if you want it as well
there will be plenty of players to do
who prefer to take on the minions of the
darkness
next week we'll share more on what to
expect in season of the worthy only one
more 12 left to go before the new season
and to Mort Wobs before trials so I
wonder if next week they cover the
seasonal stuff and then Thursday that
cover the details about trials how it's
gonna work and stuff like that do you
think they'll break it down that way
yeah I think so
are they so I think I've also big big
alluded to mourner because again your
beloved and whole supernova it's gonna
get more spoke cuz shout out to my boy
arm cool guy he's huge crowd to birth
old died he would have put me once that
that acidity with that it has to get it
cuz what's gonna happen is even with the
nerves they're gonna try to work around
it by using that exotic to get more
grenade and faster and stuff like that
so they've got to tweet that but overall
and be honest every man I felt I'm
saying hunt coming on right inside to
get it Morlocks had to get it with that
I like the military then we'll see um
other than that I wouldn't see honey at
the pker moving on some quest I like
that they're fine I mean they finally
telling us hey these are the top class
these are the ones that are stat they
pronounced without teeth now we got a
buck those on it let's get let's get
that going on again brows coming we have
to have a fair playing field that at
least the other classes in from someone
that's all yeah no I mean I agree I
think the peeler subclass changers are
good they were needed some of these have
been outstanding for a little while
there's a we got sandbox stuff changing
we've got subclasses changing there's
gonna be a little bit more I mean things
are definitely gonna get a new coat of
paint on we'll see how trials kind of
irons out there trying to really make
sure trials kind of lands the fixes with
trials coming in obviously try the power
not gonna be a bet that's huge that was
like the biggest thing all day this
could have been some stuff that was like
the biggest thing for all of this week
was Luke's miss tweet saying artifact
our won't matter I was like you just
saved a whole bunch of stuff right there
for a little
well so that was big yeah this one has
been a minute we're at 220 it is all so
we gotta let this man get ready to go
back to pack so he doesn't die you guys
have been awesome tonight yeah I gotta
say a chat has been crazy this has been
a passionate one this evening for sure I
thought we did it last week honestly I
didn't think we were gonna go at it
again I really didn't but it is a fun
one either way by though it's nothing
but love between us guys we make
different things but there's nothing but
yeah there's nothing like good times
going in here we we exactly brothers
kicked the crap out of each other
sometimes too
I know my brother and I did like oh we
were good what are the grades I kept it
and then I had to book the bear cuz it's
a hell of a lot all right you guys well
this has been bonus episode it's number
92 which throws off my timing of episode
106 see how we name these things but for
the time being you guys are awesome if
you guys listen to this on audio you can
find both of us I'll let you do your
outro real quick sorry no it's just like
no don't first of all chat with me the
fact that you guys hit up stop well
glass episode so much you guys are
treating both of us for they do about Oh
keep it bare or both side it was
absolutely hilarious didn't do you know
thing we both want the best thing for
this game and the see you guys say your
I can't paint glass work the tank like
that to me it makes me really appreciate
you guys preaching but with so that's no
more so shout out to you got the cold I
hybrid everybody who the people that is
all y'all do all of his oh he's got
looks best on that on right now
everything is
according to pan the evil exotics became
a legendary lightweight only a better
time to get it played but I gotta fight
I got a heart that loved these things
the hoarders as you call me the
seven-year guy that might be your new
title that's great guys
so yeah I'll make it fast I'm more
podcast we still have packed me to get
on economy they just keep looking at the
channel and again once again that
tremendous article to decide we're out
here repping packs in Boston be back at
the end of the week and the next week
right back into my man II for the last
word the best done for us the best
destination ever rapidly how much it let
me here state they can understand what
but again it's all fun all games - my
brother love each other we love this
game and it's great to see you guys
support us the way you do it and that's
why I like to stay up late and argue
with them think I'm crazy but yeah you
guys know where to find me as well
twitch Twitter YouTube follow me see
what I'm playing it see Bonta everywhere
if you find the cheetah you probably
tripped over my stuff if you guys do
enjoy the videos make sure you guys like
them on both channels subscribe to both
iron Lords podcast and mine the audio
will be up later as well so always make
sure you guys definitely check in to
that one the audio goes up so you guys
can take it with you on the go always a
nice way to do it but overall thank you
guys very much this has been episode 92
February 28th February is almost done
but we got an extra day this year so
thank you guys very much
and as again this has been the last word